okay welcome to any game class for
tournament players normally I do some
funny rigmarole to decide which player
but since there was an end game very
interesting and game played here last
night at the Chess Club in the norm
tournament I thought I'd just look at
that player's end games that players a
Christian korilla from Romania some
reason having a Spanish name them and he
was uh got into this winning end game
immediately blundered his opponent
played better than perfect and then
blundered as soon as it was easy and the
game was decisive okay now normally I
would choke on my own rage but there was
another game going on that was much
worse between Eric Rosen and Vladimir
gurgi of where Yerger was plus six plus
five plus four plus five plus six and
then he lost on time when he was like
slightly better pathetic okay and I have
to work in these conditions terrible
okay so but it doesn't explain why I
hardly ever lose because look at the
competition okay so black played king c7
which is a good move and well okay why
it's going to try to Queen but not now
because his rook is hanging in this kind
of ending what's important is whether
the Kings get in front of the passed
pawn white once his king in front black
once his king in front Black's not
getting his King in front because as we
say the King is cut off it can't you
know move towards the pawn because the
rook is on the D file this position
White has three moves that win and he
decided not to win later black decided
to lose as everybody was happy well rip
d4 doesn't win because we just trade the
rooks and play here and then then this
is a draw well not king c6 but King e6
and for those of you at home that are
not very good which is all of you okay
then it ends in stalemate
okay so rugby for doesn't win
however rugby 3 rib d2 and rugby 1 all
win every move wins white decided not to
win a very interesting decision the
reason it's an interesting decision is
because white knows his rooks going on
the D file so that the black king can't
saunter over where d4 is a very
elementary King and pawn ending draw so
basically white has four choices three
of them win and he chose the one that
drew and he played rook to d5 this is
bad because it's next to the black king
now if you remember what I said but it
was two minutes ago so you should rewind
it home blacks goal is to get the King
in front of the pawn which isn't going
to happen and White's goal is to get the
king in front of the pawn which will
happen if the white king is in front of
the pawn how do we check him away do we
check him away from the green arrow or
from the red arrow if the white King is
in front of the pawn the red arrow okay
because you can't check him from where
the green arrow is now this is the part
of the game that doesn't make any sense
black played perfect and was drawing and
did everything right and then as soon as
was a very easy draw he changed his mind
and decided to lose which I don't I
don't get so he played the only drawing
move which I've already told you where
was the red arrow yeah okay that's the
only move that draws now I'm not telling
you this because I know that's the only
move the draw is I don't know anything
but I do know how to access table bases
and table base so that's the only move
the draws also I know you want your work
to be in front of the pawn to check now
if the white rook was behind not on d5
black wouldn't be able to play king c6
attacking the rook which is what
happened why play d4 and black played
rook check the only move the draws and
the thing is if you start move
your king up then you start losing your
pawn okay and so you can't do that so
you have to play some other King move
and now black played the only move the
draws very nice taking advantage of the
rook on d5 if the rook was on d1 d2 or
d3 this is a win this move prevents the
white pawn from moving
yes King c6 if the rook was on d1 d2 or
d3 white plays a 5 and wins if now white
plays e5 somebody else wins okay so why
can't do anything if he protects his
pawn with his King the rook checks you
attacks the pawn and you got nothing
white realized that he had nothing here
he knew what was up so he played a very
sneaky move he made a move that did
nothing yeah this is actually a very
good move if he tries to do something
there's nothing to do you want to keep
your rook on the D line so that the
black King Ken doesn't walk over so he
played rook to d4 and now if it's
White's move white plays a 5 so black
played king c5 because otherwise this
pawn is protected and if you go in front
and I'm like hey I want to push my pawn
and you check me now I'm going to push
my pawn so you have to play king c5 and
say get your work out of there okay and
why it's like oh well that didn't work
and he checks them back the same
position always repeat good job mr.
carala so now white play King g5 and
said it's your move and black said I
have a good idea let's lose the game
immediately okay and this is the first
position where every move draws previous
to this black had one move that drew in
every position now black doesn't have to
move it it's a draw King g5 does nothing
all rook moves on the back rank that
don't hang the rook or a draw I think I
think Rick see it's a drawl so Rick G
it's not good because he takes it okay
and we already discussed this
and it's not like that I know it because
I'm cheating
I mean that is why I know it but he
knows it because he already did it I'm
like he played were ak8 he played rook
FA he did everything right
he put his rook in front of the pawn
white wants to get his king in front of
the pawn and then Queen his pawn he
can't because of where the rook is so
for example a trick H a anywhere
okay so again if white moves this King
over we're going to check them and you
can't you can't go here or here because
I take your pawn and if you go to f5
okay great
Rey and then no and nothing's happening
there's nothing going on and black
decided this is too easy I'm going to
lose I wonder if he actually decided
that and he played rook F 1 now I
understand if black had played rook a1
when the game started that we looked at
because he doesn't know how to draw but
he played a rookie a rookie f8 showing
he does at a draw then he forgot the
next move now if White's King goes in
front of the pawn that's a we can't
check him he just starts moving as king
of wanna okay now obviously why can't
move his pawn now because King takes
rook why if you play e5 you lose you're
up so he moved his rook away and now
it's already winning it's over I'm going
to play e5 e6 rawr and if you put your
rook behind my pawn I put my king in
front of my pawn and I just pushed them
up now it's too late to play rook f8
because I play e5 if the pawn was on e4
this would draw what the pawns on e5 and
we're going to play e6 and so forth so
after Rick d2 it's over and we get a
Lucina type position which any
tournament come player can win except
Harper Evan Smith that made me even
madder I'm never going to get over that
yeah and if there's a beginner beatdown
next week and I'm not doing it which I
hope is the case I got to give my
commercial him the game between Doug
Acker and Harper Evan Smith where it was
a lucena position and then he just
didn't win and I agreed to a draw okay
this is a very well-known position no
matter where the pawn is you build a
bridge you stop the checks you Queen
Harper evan smith rated 1940 had no idea
to win this position and he didn't win
against a master would have been the
first master he ever be it they'll never
beat one again i guarantee that that was
his only hope i would be meaner but i
don't know how joke you know how could I
make more fun of Harper Evan Smith but
but but if you if you had lucina's
position against Acker he would win with
less than a second with no delay no and
no increment but he had no idea he's
like how do you win like your knight
he's like I know how to win but I forgot
okay now I mean Shonda is not resigning
here for some reason
like a Grand Master okay so he played
some silly move okay then rook F 2 and
okay resigns then I queen next move okay
so the way to win this position assuming
black isn't silly notice how white can't
move his King anywhere so the first
thing we do is we have our rook block
the checks we check them away now we're
going to queen gray and now we're going
to queen okay and now we're going to
play rook here rook here and if you
checks us we go here and we block the
checks and we win this has been known
since before chess was invented this
method okay and so Chandra knew that
that was winning so Toronto just played
a silly move were k1 okay and then he
resigned no okay so that anything was a
win that it was a draw than it was a win
since I get paid by the hour let's go
back so King c7 every rook move wins rug
d3 rug d2 rigged d1 he found the only
move that didn't win now it's a draw and
the reason it's a draw is we attack the
rook and the pawn can't move forward if
the white rook was on any of these
squares
why would play e5 e6 e7 which now is a
bad idea
okay
and you can't do that so he played King
g5 said would you move your rook to the
worst square please and blacks like sure
there you go now you can win and whites
like thank you now of course if blacks
rook was on FA he would play rookie a
rookie fate check work yet rook f8 check
but now since white wants to hide his
King here and the only place you can
check is here now you're winning 'if
I've is the threat so that's over and
this is just well known to everybody
very something for those guys
very strange move rook f1 especially
when he played rook a a the only drawing
move I was following this last night and
very upset I was like rook g5 the only
move that doesn't win and then black
played perfect perfect every move
perfect and then here when every move
drew he played rook f1 all these moves
draw just keep your look there and the
guy can't move his pawn forward or move
his King forward we're are furious okay
that stuff happens now since korilla won
that end game which he shouldn't have
won although he should have won then he
shouldn't have won I figure we'll look
at his game look at his great end games
and he's been to our chess club more
than once and most of his games are from
Romania because he's from Romania good
reason this game I really liked uh now
gorillas for some reason his name
doesn't end in a u so we have to start
an investigation that you ready Ben
Simon if you're male and you're from
Romania name ends into you if it doesn't
and I want I demand an investigation now
his opponent this was playing the
Romanian championship notice his name
ends in you so he's okay yeah I don't
know why camera listen I'm going to ask
him at dinner tonight
do your Neiman's in an a and he'll be
like yeah I'm really from Brazil yeah
okay now this end game I like black took
the night obviously whites up an
exchange but I mean he's got doubled
pawns and they're like attacked and
blocked these pawns aren't very good
black has good drawing chances so I
really like the
first move of this endgame he puts black
to a decision of what to do about these
B pawns and he plays b3 so now if you
take this beep on you're going to lose
all of your pawns like this Shadegg x'
b5 rook takes threatening the bishop
twice and threatening rook takes g5
check very nice if you take the other b
pawn which he did now I can protect this
be pawn with the rook behind the pawn
which is what you want and so that's
what he did so actually getting rid of
this pawn was a good idea now his pawns
extra protected ok now he played b6
because you want to Queen your pawn King
h7 and he played h3 so his King wasn't
tied down the back rank and he's
stopping g4 and now he did something
likes all my students to do I'm still
waiting for one of them to do it when
they do let me know been activated his
King King should go up that would be a
good move let's see if I can do it
nope okay so King up so he played rugby
for first which stops d4 okay that's
even better then you play King f1 King
Ditu King at King King moving up every
time and now he played rook c5 which I
like and the idea is you want to play b7
b8
but if you play rook a7 and then play b7
your rook on a7 is trapped so he wants
to play rook c7 and then b7 his work on
c7 has thousands of squares this move I
like King g6 terrible rooks e7 b7 now
we're talking
King e5 this is a blunder
although blacks already losing and it's
really hard to see why this is a blunder
so I give him a break so he gets a break
first it's hard to see it's a blunder
and second his name ends in you so I
give the guy a break
what does your name end in you didn't
think so okay he plays king e5 now
there's a very nice tactical trick that
wins for white anyone anyone at home
exactly well you have to play rook takes
pawn and now you check and take the
bishop that's defending the rook very
sneaky let's see his opponent read
twenty one fifty that explains something
although how do you get such a good
position right and now you're just up a
ruck but this was very nice because if
the white rook was here that's not a
good square for your white rook there
now c7 there's a good square so white
moved his king up blocking the pawn
advanced his own past spawn and made it
work sir his rooks were really strong
that black might have been worried about
getting checkmated by the two rooks so
that's how the game ended for some
reason he played rook h7 instead of the
better move what we're doing we need him
Julian's favorite move resigns Yeah
right it goes down a rook if you take
this truck I take this rook then White's
up a ruck okay and then man the guy put
on a long time alright then the guy
resigned here goes down a rook and
losing all of his pawns that was a very
nice endgame because well not only did
he win but he advanced his past pawn
while keeping both of his rooks active
and he made his King active he did
everything he took his time yeah and
okay King e5 is a mistake but I think it
doesn't matter here maybe g4 naba
shouldn't matter because I'm going to
check you and make you play King e5 no
but that's okay then the rooks not
defending the other ik so yeah he should
have made a waiting move I don't know if
the waiting move is though King g6
that's terrible King g6 things made yeah
so he was in looks long here amazing
can't move anything terrible King e6
forced King g5 losing immediately
wait King e6 loses for the same reason
yeah so this is a funny look as one you
can't move anything the main point of
this ending for me not for anybody else
most people are like hey that pawns
queening hey i like the king moving over
in stopping this pawn because then black
and do anything okay very nice game
unlike the other one where I've never
been so angry never okay now this was
played that Utd because a lot of the
foreign players in the US who are
playing in this tournament and who are
IMS and GM's are going to utd UMBC
Webster Texas Tech u UT Brownsville and
Lindenwood and that's it I mean there's
some other schools and we have a lot of
GM norm tournaments because we have
these foreign players that compliant now
this looks pretty drawn because it's
rook and three against rook and three
but just because it looks drawn and is
drawn doesn't mean it will be drawn okay
white has a big advantage
I will accept three answers name one of
White's advantages let's call on
somebody at home first you yeah you at
home nothing as usual terrible anybody
else want to give a try what are some of
whites advantages the what the awesome
pawns way these pawns are awesome these
are way those are the only pawns
a better pawn structure black has an
isolated pawn backward pawn white spawns
are awesome yeah that's the technical
term I just didn't know it
awesome puns anyone else anyone yeah
yeah I think that's the main advantage
if blacks king was on b6 they would
agree to a draw but blacks King is cut
off and so yeah I'm sort of the king up
so white spawns are better because
blacks are easily attacked and blacks
king is cut off so computer says white
is a little better but I think
practically speaking white is more than
a little better it's hard to play black
here okay he defended his pawn and now
white activated his King King c1 King D
2 and White's like no you're not you're
not going to move your king over and
when white moves his king up his rook is
defending his awesome pawns so I like
rook F to a defends and it attacks rook
c4 King d3 rook h4 two can play that
game we're cutting off blacks King black
is cutting off White's King b3 stopping
blacks pawns for moving Rick h1 well if
I was black I would have a problem here
I don't want to play King g7 because
Rick f5 looks pretty annoying if I play
King g5 I'm probably worried about the
Rope coming in this way which he could
have done in any case so I might have
played King g5 he played rook h1 trying
to attack king d4 he did attack and now
see for the rook defends the a pawn and
again black is playing without a king if
blacks king was over here that would be
better
took on Poisson he took now the pawns
are both isolated but there's not so
many on the board again if blacks King
was on the Queen side oh just be a
draw rub d1 defending f4 is wants to
play rugby for he wants to play rook a
for it's hard to defend both of these
pawns check attacks the pawn defends the
pawn and eventually black decides I
don't want my pawn taken so he gets to
pass pawns
so all they can take it and get doubled
pawns fact the computer is unsure here
whether white should take or just play
b4 I know what I would do I always take
pawns so he took like I would have now
if this pawn was in here it would be
easy for blacks to get behind the pawn
and try to stop them now it's not so
easy because the rook is defending this
pawn so when I push this pawn it's hard
to stop again if black had a king and
his King was you know somewhere on the
Queen side it'd just be a draw okay so
d4 counter play d3 counter play exciting
rook check and now in the long run
blacks just going to lose because blacks
going to lose this pawn and this pawn is
going to queen so black played the
trickiest threw he could find rook c2
recommended by Run DMC right Joe yeah so
if we trade rooks and both sides Queen
that would be a theoretical draw and a
practical draw you'd never win that
position you could try to win but you're
not going to win okay and there's
there's no way you can stop checking
ever you can never go on this diagonal
because you'll lose your queen you can't
go on this file because you'll lose your
pawn so I'm just going to always check
you and it's going to be a draw but
White has one move it wins that's enough
you only need one move
somebody said it really quietly he was
somebody home
that's how quiet it was who said it
really quietly Ritchie to check that
does win but for black yeah wait that
was you that said that no wonder you're
sitting back there you a seven okay you
can't play rook takes a two because
white would do the same thing okay so
it's up to the rock queen and black put
his pawn on the seventh rank maybe
that's enough to draw but no Queen da
and White has another pawn right alright
let's have the room vote because the
rooms usually not too good at this we're
going to not let you vote for Buchanan's
that's usually a mistake should white
play Queen takes pawn or not play Queen
takes pawn that is the question whether
it says nobler in the mind to give away
your queen or to take arms against a sea
of past pawns and by trading end them to
die to Sleep No More you know you know
the restaurant it looked up in a
dictionary okay
dictionary what a class okay so who says
Queen takes D two thumbs up who says no
Queen takes D 2 and who votes for Hamlet
anyone and look it usually in Hamlet we
play Bishop III in the opening to be e3
or not to be III that is the question
Queen takes deets who is a mistake
because after we trade the black King
runs over and this would be a draw you
could try to Queen and in fact you can
Queen and then the guy takes it
okay so Queen d2 wasn't played instead
he played a5 now we're talking you with
some crazy comment
well if I play rookie three you can't
but it might win might not win I'm too
old to figure it out queen d3 your idea
is that this wins okay as opposed to
every other move winning you want your
insisted on giving your queen away okay
you don't do that as we discussed in
hundreds of lessons
okay now rookie three I'm too old to
figure out it is about too old to figure
it out yeah every move wins but giving
your queen away doesn't in this position
given the Queen way the way you did
there you can win a five show at White
has no interest in giving his Queen away
he's more interested in queening his own
pawn and black didn't like that black
was like once you give her Queen away
okay and then black did the usual what
was Julian he resigned yet because pawn
is pretty strong that pawn is not as
strong it's easily stopped so white one
rook and three versus Rick in three
mainly because the black king was never
getting over and helping out not very
helpful okay and then let's see we do
this we spin around a little this I've
rarely seen this is my favorite of the
end games now why is it my favorite it
was I liked it and it's the last one I
get to leave so it's about good for two
reasons now here white has more space
and white played the move that you would
all play yeah very good yeah I'm gonna
give an easy one White has more space
and black has to be careful that White's
going to advance on both wings and try
to win that way f5 yeah I'm not a fan of
f5 black didn't want to defend defend
defend defend so he broke out normally
when you're defending and you're worse
and you have less space and you're
playing for a draw you're trying to
trade pawns if there's no pawns on the
board it's unlikely a bishop at night
will be the bishop at night although if
your play
outside the Chess Club some of those
guys okay so f5 taking on pissant some
of you didn't know that rule takes 95
check now I'm guessing black was
surprised by 95 check because trade
trade trade trade how are you going to
win okay and now we're going to vote
again probably you'll get the wrong
answer because you're uninformed voters
you know Americans typical now that's a
a funny voting story true story those of
you who are watching in Europe won't
believe me but I was there in nineteen
they don't know
88 I'm close might have been 89 there
was a vote in Amsterdam to eliminate
cars no cars true story you know because
they got canals and bikes and trams and
buses and they voted to eliminate cars
they voted however they did not
eliminate cars because not enough people
voted the vote didn't count there had to
be some percentage and they got like 1%
people voted so so we're going to vote
here except you're all going to vote you
can vote for D takes or F takes now my
students I was going to call them
something else but we're being
videotaped my students which ever move
they would play they would write xe5
Jono's won't talking about then I would
say which one and they would not know
and they would randomly guess and be
wrong oh yeah I took with a half-point I
remember then was who played the game
over obviously took with a D pawn
because f5 was played in King before
okay so should white play the red move
or the green move who votes for D takes
d5 the red move then who votes for F
takes e5 well what did I say but I call
D takes e5 the green move I like that
all right who votes for F takes e5 the
other green move all right and as usual
the uninformed class is wrong and the
lowest-rated players are correct yeah
took with the
upon this gives white two ways to win
that way or that way or for you that way
or that way
because you're seeing the opposite
million so now my bishop can come in
here and take or my king can come in
here or I can do both and a third one I
won't tell you cuz that give the answer
why I was shocked at the end of this
game I was very impressed I'm actually
going to tell him about it I'll say that
game that you won again it's table and
they'll say what I didn't play that game
that was my brother so D takes is better
because after F takes this Bishop isn't
very good I mean you can't we can't do
any tricks now we can do tricks okay
King c6 defending the pawn bishop d4 is
useless White's like okay you defend
your pawn and then why it's like all
right now I'm going to come beat you
awesome right how does the knight get to
f7 or h7 to prevent the king from coming
in good answer good answer so blacks
like no problem I'm going to save my
pawn and then my king is going to run
over and stop yeah haha see and then you
can't come in I don't care okay now
white plays Bishop to b6 and Bishop to
Bishop to d8 I love Bishop to d8 the
idea is we're going to stop the King
from coming and we're going to put black
in zugzwang
so for example if King goes to e8
actually you might have played King it
let me say they put an idea if the King
goes to EA and we attack your knight you
have to play King f7 and now white can
win in the same way that he wanted the
game which really surprised me so we'll
save that for later so he played 98 and
he's like dude I stopped everything
you're going to do but Y can do
something he didn't try yet he tried
attacking the pawn on d6 with his bishop
the pawn moved away he tried to play
king h4 king g5 black moved his King
over but now it's a bishop on da this
black King can't move over this way so
what did we do yeah yeah now you went
back the other way yeah kingi three he's
like okay I'll win this way whatever
okay
and now well it's not easy to get back
over there
because your knight has nowhere to go
and if you go to g7 with the idea of
King e8 then when I play Bishop f6 your
king is going back to f7 you have no
space you can't do anything
so Knight g7 and the King walks over
King e8 to you know go to c6 and stop
them Bishop f6 you got to defend your
knight King III and the King just walks
in yeah when I take on a six you're not
going to be very happy and I can stop
your D pawn pretty easily
Bishop age 41 for example so a knight
there bishop d8 now you can't move the
knight anywhere then you can't move the
King anywhere so my King is going to
come in here and you're going to lose
also even if white didn't want to win
some people want to win some don't the
black still can't do anything but just
has no moves so for example if I was
doing this with white probably before I
took you're a pawn I would play Bishop
here this ship here you know drunkenly
Bishop F to king c5 and then my bishops
already stopping your pawn so that was
very nice the way he uses Bishop to
attack the pawn he uses Kingdom a that
when black stopped everything black
would stop the King from coming back
pretty good concerning the first ending
replay drug d5 now some of you and most
of you at home
and everybody on the Internet are
dissing all of our best players today
claiming players from 30 40 50 60 80
years ago play the endgame better they
had two advantages one is they would
adjourn games that analyze the endgame
with their friends and the other is we
have sudden-death and where games go
four five six seven hours
if you've played for six hours and
you're playing two games a day and
you're playing six days in a row you're
tired when you're playing the end game
so the end games aren't played as well
today because people are exhausted and
they're not a during the games looking
at with their friends so end game play
was better what you could cheat now when
you're tired and you can't cheat the
play goes down a little but this was
very nice because you just sauntering
with your King and there's nothing that
black can do black is too passive I
really like D takes e5 because black has
so many things to worry about
well black didn't worry anymore because
he resigned here in fact it's very hard
to play a legal move here for black I
guess Knight g7 and then if you try to
run your King over I do it again and you
got to go back here again it's funny
unless you're black then it's not it's
funny and then Bishop d8 again and you
can't move again and life's tough
although here I think I would play
Bishop h4 and then Bishop f2 to stop the
counter play and then num
yum-yum-yum-yum
that's the technical term right Ben yeah
okay so that's funny normally I do a
lecture on one of the world's top
players and instead I do it on some guy
who's got 50% here that's pretty good
but I'll talk to him by the dinner and
Tom what a great player he is
you think you'll believe me yeah I'll
trick them